JOHN LUTHER: Good morning.
How's everybody?
OK, Glass present slide.
Now wait a minute.
It's fun to pretend, right?
FRANK GALLIGAN: We're not cool
enough to have Glass.
JOHN LUTHER: You'd think
we would be.
Good morning.
Welcome to our session on WebM,
demystifying video coding.
My name's John Luther.
I'm the Product Manager at
Google for WebM and for video
technology in the
Chrome browser.
And this is my colleague and
co-presenter Frank Galligan,
Staff Software Engineer at
Google also working on WebM
and Chrome.
And they tell you to
open with a joke.
And my joke is my picture.
This looks so sad
about something.
FRANK GALLIGAN: You
look orange.
JOHN LUTHER: I know.
All right.
So what's to demystify?
First, I'm going to just give
sort of an overview of what
WebM is and VP8, but mostly
going to focus on the video
side with WebM today, and then
the reasons why WebM is a
great choice for developers
to do video in their apps.
I'm going to give some examples
of how to encode WebM
video using ffmpeg, which is a
very popular command line and
coding tool used by pretty much
every video service on
earth these days, including
YouTube.
So Frank will then do his part
of the presentation on how to
actually build WebM into apps
using our open source
libraries, libvpx, the WebM
container library which is our
wrapper format and libvorbis,
which is our audio encoder.
He'll then--
if everything goes according
to plan--
encode a video on an Android
device, upload it to YouTube
where it will instantaneously
appear to the world.
And then I'll just touch briefly
on what we're up to
next, which is our VP9,
which is our next
generation video codec.
And we'll have a quick
Q&A. And then we'll
let you go to lunch.
So how many people know
what WebM is?
That's OK.
That's good.
For those of you who don't, WebM
is a high-quality, open,
royalty-free alternative
for web video.
What does that mean?
That means that it's
three things.
That's this is how we define
WebM for consistency's sake.
It's the VP8 video codec.
Soon we're going to add VP9.
Vorbis audio, which is a
royalty-free, very good audio
codec that's developed by
the Xiph foundation.
And it's a Matroska-based
file container.
What that means is the audio
and video streams are
contained in a Matroska file
container, but we use a file
extension WebM to differentiate
it from other
files, because any user agent
or client, we want to make
sure that when they receive
a file of .webm type or
MIME-type WebM that they can
always know that it's going to
be these three things, and
later VP9 and opus.
So benefits for developers.
Why would a developer
want to use WebM?
Well, more than anything, of
course, is the video quality.
The VP8 Kodak was developed by a
small company called on OnTo
Technologies, where Frank
and I came from.
Google acquired OnTo
in 2010 and open
sourced VP8 for the world.
So if you look at the quality
that VP8 can achieve just sort
of as a base to judge
these things--
1080p HD video is obviously
very difficult to transmit
over networks, because
it's so many
gigantic frames of pixels.
But with VP8, we can achieve
very good-looking, high PSNR,
which is how these things
are usually measured.
1080p at about three megabits.
So most residential, consumer,
internet connections nowadays,
they're getting there, to the
point where people have a sort
of predictable--
at least, we would hope-- three
megabits connection.
But you could even do 720
at lower than this.
So that's one gauge of
how you can judge it.
Simplicity of design.
So VP8 is unlike other codecs
that you might know of in that
we design it to be completely
compliant across any decoder.
So if any valid VP8 stream that
you create will decode
and playback in any compliant
VP8 decoder--
Why is that different
than other codecs.
Well, other codecs, let's say,
for example, H.264--
they have different profiles
that are defined.
So H.264 baseline, H.264 main.
This leads one to believe that
those are inter-compatible but
they're not.
The main profile decoder cannot
decode a baseline bitstream.
They're essentially three
different codecs or more.
There's baseline,
main and high.
So with VP8, you never have
to worry about that.
So if you have, for example, if
you want to serve video to
Glass users as well as users on
MacBooks, the Glass users,
Glass only supports baseline.
These support high profile.
So you'd have to have different
bitstreams for
different clients.
And you'd always have to be
doing user agent checking.
What does this one support,
and so on.
With VP8, you don't have to
worry about that, because
there are no profiles.
There are no levels, which is
another way that codecs were
defined by what's the maximum
frame size of this video, bit
rate, so forth.
We don't do B-frames, which are
kind of a way to predict
forward or backward
in the video.
No IDR frames.
We try to keep it as simple as
possible, yet we do achieve
the same quality as something
like H.264 High Profile.
On the other side of the
equation, the decoding, we try
to keep it very low complexity,
meaning that it's
very important for us that VVP8
run fast in software,
even on lower power devices.
I think a lot of times we in the
Western world forget that
not everybody buys a new
computer every year
or every two years.
There's still a lot of devices
in the world that have a very
hard time decoding other
codecs and software.
VP8 opens that world up to more
users, because it can
decode on an even lower power,
older generation ARM
processors, which-- there are
still many, many of those in
the world today.
It's also very widely
supported.
So WebM, as a format, in the
video tag in desktop web
browsers, this is just some
data I pulled from
StatCounter.
So native WebM meaning you
install the browser.
It's WebM capable
out of the box.
Has about 60% of browsers in
use in the world today.
So that means Chrome, Firefox,
Opera a browser that's built
on top of chromium.
It's in the chromium source.
It's in Firefox-- you know
the gecko stuff?
Anyway the light green segment
is browsers that we can
address with plug-ins, which
are freely available and
downloadable from our website.
This is primarily IE9 and 10
and Safari 5 and later.
The gray slice is browsers that
not necessarily don't
support WebM, but just simply
don't support HTML5 video
which is IE8, IE7, a lot of the
older browsers that are
still out there in use today,
but don't have the
capabilities.
So adding it all up, the dark
green wedge is actually
growing pretty fast over time.
So you can be pretty confident
that in some way your users
will be able to play WebM.
So also as an--
I was curious about mobile.
Tablets are obviously very
becoming very important
platforms for media consumption,
playing videos,
so I wondered OK, well, in the
aggregate worldwide, what
percentage of tablets support
WebM natively.
And it turns out it's
about 43.4%.
So this is obviously--
a lot of this is Android.
And as you heard yesterday in
the keynote, Android is
growing at a kind of
a moderate rate, I
guess you might say.
So anywhere where Android grows,
WebM grows, because
it's supported in the
Android source
repository out of the box.
There's also more hardware
coming online for VP8.
This is a topic that everybody
likes to discuss.
VP8--
hardware support is important to
devices, low power devices
especially, something that's
not plugged into a wall.
So if it has a battery, you want
to conserve as much of
that battery as possible.
Doing video, encoding and
decoding operations and
hardware is much, much
less power intense
than doing it in software.
So anyway, a lot of that's
started to come
in the market now.
Their VP8 decoder's coming to
market pretty much every major
SOC vendor, which is SOC-- the
ARM chip vendors, who have--
there's an arm corps
of the sock.
But then it has blocks for
hardware operations
like video and audio.
Pretty much every major
arm-based sock vendor is now
much shipping chips
with VP8 decoding.
And they're starting to come in
the market and things like
the Samsung Chromebooks, Nexus
10, Samsung Galaxy S4, those
types of devices.
So as an example of what
I mentioned about the
complexity, YouTube obviously
wanted to support the Wii.
There's many of those devices
in the world.
And a lot of users love them.
They want to play YouTube
video on them.
But the problem they kept
running into is due to some
platform limitations that
Nintendo puts in place, they
couldn't access the hardware to
do the video in hardware.
And they're doing it in
software, they had other
limitations where the .264
streams didn't have the
horsepower to play them back.
And then the .263 streams, they
just weren't getting the
quality that they thought
the users deserved.
So they said what about VP8?
We ported and optimized VP8 for
that platform, and now Wii
client in the world
gets WebM video.
And that market is now open
to all those users.
So that's an example where the
simplicity of the designs that
we always strive for end up
paying off in the end.
So perhaps most importantly,
WebM is free.
That means both senses of the
word as people know it--
beer and speech.
We don't charge any
money for WebM.
VP8, Matroska, Vorbis are all
royalty-free technologies.
And it's all open source.
The VP8 codec is in a
repository in the
WebMproject.org website.
Anybody's free to use it.
It's under a BSD license,
which is one of the more
liberal open source licenses.
It means anybody can fork it.
I've even had customers ask me
if I use it, do I have to
still call VP8.
And you don't.
You can call it whatever
you want.
That's the beauty of
the BSD license.
So why is this important
to developers.
It's important because other
codecs can cost you millions
of dollars a year.
And that's not an
exaggeration.
A lot of standards-based
codecs have royalties
associated with them.
It has nothing to do with
the standards groups.
They just assemble
the technologies
and write the specs.
It's the people on patents that
are relevant to those
standards that then form pools
to charge royalties for them.
The H.264 and VC-1 royalty
pools today have maximum
annual royalties of $6.5
million a year.
For apps, it's sort of a scaling
sliding scale, but
it's basically $0.20 a unit of
every app that you sell.
So what does that mean to you?
Let's say you're an Android
developer, and you have an app
that you want to do video coding
like Frank's going to
demonstrate.
Let's say you put it in the
Play Store, and you charge
$0.99 for it.
$0.20 of every sale you make
goes to a pooling organization
called [INAUDIBLE], up
to the cap of $6 and
1/2 million a year.
This is even applicable if your
app is free, because the
royalty is to use
the technology.
It's not a share of the money
you make or anything else.
If your app has just does
content in those formats--
let's say, you are able to sort
of take advantage of the
codec that's in the Android
platform SDK or hardware, if
you're charging users any amount
of money to consume
that content, you're going
to owe royalties as well.
So none of this, thankfully,
applies to WebM.
It's all free.
It's all open.
Anybody can use it, and now
owe anybody any money.
So that's all the great
properties of it.
I'm just going to show you
how to actually make
one of these files.
Who understands how video
compression works?
Probably most of you, right?
OK.
The primary aim of any kind of
compression but particularly
video is to remove redundancies
of data.
With video, you have
redundancies within frames of
video that's called spatial
redundancy.
Temporal redundancy is things
that are similar in
a sequence of frames.
You can get rid of
all that stuff.
Statistical redundancy--
redundancy in the data stream
itself00 the ones and zeros.
Take those out.
There's perceptual--
it's called redundancy,
but it's not quite.
It's just things that the human
eye can't even perceive.
Just take those out.
So you take all these things out
with the ultimate goal of
removing them, yet keeping the
quality as close as you
possibly can to the original
source video.
This is the way this is the
art of the technology.
How do you do all this, yet when
you reconstruct the image
from the compressed bitstream,
what the user sees is, you
hope, imperceptible from
what you started from.
So raw video--
video right off of a camera and
editing deck, whatever--
if you just have all those
full pixels, it's not
compressed at all.
It's gigantic.
So let's say this video
that I'm going to
encode is not even HD.
It's around standard
definition.
It's 17 seconds long, just for
the sake of brevity here.
Yet it's 320 megabytes,
that file.
So I don't know about you, but
my network at home can't serve
that data rate.
I don't know, maybe if you had
fiber, maybe, but even then
probably not.
Audio, same case.
The raw audio stream I'm going
to use, which is PCM samples,
is three megabytes.
I got 17 seconds.
So how are we going to get 323
megabytes of data over a
network to a user
in 17 seconds.
Well, we're going to use ffmpeg
We're going to combine
these streams, which is called
muxing, multiplexing.
We're then going to run
them through ffmpeg.
And this is represented by this
clever spinning logo.
This is where all that magic
that I talked about happens.
This is where the codec is going
to look at these frames
of video and look at all the
redundancies and just pull
them all out, compress it
all down into a stream.
And the final result
is going to be a
WebM file of 1.9 megabytes.
So we took 323 megabytes worth
of raw data, and now this is
something that 17 seconds, 1.9
megabytes, easily can be
served to pretty much any user,
even maybe even over a
3G connection.
So let's look at how
this is done.
This is the example.
I have a couple examples
in this slide.
You'll be able to download them
later on and play around
with them yourself.
You can modify them.
There are other options.
You can go as deep into this
stuff as you want.
But one of the beauties of VP8
and WebM is that we have,
again, with simplicity in mind,
you don't have to be an
expert in this stuff.
You don't have to hire
consultants to show you
exactly every parameter
required to do this.
Pretty much if you put a video
into the libvpx compressor, it
makes a lot of the hard
decisions for you.
What comes out there is, in
most cases, pretty great.
So let's just step through
these parameters here.
First is the binary--
ffmpeg.
That's the program.
The dot i is the input video.
Again, this is a raw stream,
Y4M, just raw pixel data.
Same with the audio, just
a WAV file, PCM samples.
This -c v parameter is libvpx.
That's the library that we
at the WebM project make
available in source or binary
from the website.
Does all the VP8
encoding magic.
-b v is the bit rate.
So I'm going to set the target
bit-rate of this file to 800
kilobits per second.
What does that mean?
That means I tell the encoder I
say OK, if you could encode
any frame or segment or one
second's worth of video in
these streams, with using less
than 800 kilobits of
data, go for it.
That's great.
Yet don't exceed that.
Because my target use case,
I know that my users--
let's say, I know from market
research, whatever-- that most
of my users don't have any more
than a megabit reliable
connectivity.
So with overhead and audio, I
want to keep that well below
one megabit a second.
So I'm going to specify
800 kilobits as
my target data rate.
Quality setting is just--
in the VP8 coder, there's
three settings--
real time, best and good.
Best and good are kind of
misnomers, in that yes, best
will give you the absolute
best quality.
But in most cases, good
is just that.
It's good enough.
And it runs faster.
The best quality will give you
the best output, but it is, in
some cases, depending on the
material, can be significantly
more intense and take
longer to encode.
So this next is just the
video filter, the -vf.
There are a number of filters
that you can use an ffmpeg to
do all sorts of things like--
scaling is one of them.
So I'm going to scale
this video.
Right now, it's a little bit
bigger than standard
definition.
I'm going to scale down to
standard definition, which is
480 pixels high.
The negative one is I'm saying
OK, I want you make it 480
pixels high, but the width--
I want you to keep it
proportional to the input, to
that Y4M file.
So this means that it's going
to scale it proportionally.
Whatever that width ends
up being, that's what
it's going to be.
This prevents things like if you
use the defaults, in some
cases it'll scale-- if you say
scale 480, but you don't
preserve the aspect, you get
these videos with people
stretched out or squished.
So in pretty much every case,
you want to preserve the
aspect ratio.
Last arguments are just
for libvorbis.
This is the audio encoder,
also freely available.
And I'm just going to use the
default settings there, which
are good enough for
this use case.
And the last one is the output
file, which is cleverly enough
called of W480.webm.
So just like on the old cooking
shows, through the
magic of technology, I happen
to have one of these already
ready to go.
So let's see what happens.
Now it just spit out a bunch
of scary looking stuff.
It's not that scary.
All this is mostly some
information about how this
particular instance of ffmpeg
was compiled-- all the flags
and things.
The interesting stuff here is
the sort of purple text.
So it's saying OK, I see that
you've handed me a Y4M file.
It does some piping magic to
handle those types of files.
These are the properties
of it.
It's just telling me look, there
are no time codes or
anything here.
So this might be inaccurate.
I'm going to guess.
That's usually good enough.
Same with the audio.
It says OK, this is what
you're hading me.
You already have one of these
files there, because you've
tested it in your hotel
room this morning.
Are you sure you want
to blow that away?
And I say sure, let's
go for it.
So now the magic starts.
All those things I talked
about, again, with the
redundancies, removing all
these things that are not
needed to reconstruct this
image later using a
decompressor.
So you can see down at
the bottom, the final
file size is growing.
The bit-rate, in some sections,
is exceeding but
overall, it's going-- across the
breadth of it should stay
below and we're done.
So let's see how we did.
As I said, the aim of this is
to make what comes out as
close as possible to what went
in from visual perspective.
So we forgot to plug
in the audio.
Trust me, there's audio.
And these screen, it's
always hard.
Projectors don't--
the fidelity's
usually not so great.
But you can see this looks
pretty good, right?
This is only 800 kilobits a
second of data, which Frank
and I've been in this business
for probably--
I don't want--
FRANK GALLIGAN: 15?
JOHN LUTHER: Long enough for
you to gray hairs in your
[INAUDIBLE].
When we started in this, the
idea of doing a standard
definition video at 800 kilobits
was preposterous.
Back then, we were using 300
kilobits to do little postage
size videos.
So it's pretty remarkable how
far the technology has come.
OK, so I have a number
of these examples.
I want to give Frank his time.
So you can look through these
later when you download.
Just two pass, again,
more quality,
but it'll take longer.
This is an example here of
running the encoder in a real
time mode to make it run faster,
which will slightly
degrade the quality, but it
will be done in real time.
And I just have an example here
of how you would do this
for a mobile use case.
So there's lots of information
on our site
and around the internet.
I put some links in here
about using ffmpeg
and some other things.
And this is where I hand
it over to Frank.
FRANK GALLIGAN: Thanks, John.
So John showed you one way to
encode videos on the desktop.
I'm going to show you another
method of adding audio and
video coding to your Android
applications.
I'm going to use a project
called WebM JNI bindings.
I have two demos.
And then I'm going
take a little--
time permitting-- a little
closer look at the code.
So the WebM JNI bindings
allows your Android
applications to interface with
five open source projects.
The code in the green boxes is
the Java JNI code that your
application will call.
The code in the orange
box is the C, C++
code of the JNI bindings.
Most of the code in the orange
box is just a pass through
from the Java NI bindings
to the C,
C++ open source projects.
There is a Vorbis encoder object
class that makes it
easier to add Vorbis encoding.
Also has some specific functions
for Vorbis with
regards to WebM files.
And all the code in the green
and orange boxes is what's
comprising the WebM
JNI bindings.
The code in the blue boxes is
the open source code that
really does all the heavy
lifting, does the converting,
does the encoding,
does the muxing.
And most of the code in the blue
boxes is hand optimized
for ARM, as well as x86.
Also in the JNI bindings is
a readme.android file.
The readme tells you how to set
everything up, where to
get the open source code, how
to build them and how to get
ready to add audio and video
encoding to your project.
So with that, I'll show
our first demo.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to add audio and-- oops,
should be coming soon-- anyways,
I'm going to add
audio and video encoding to an
Android device using the WebM
JNI bindings.
I'm using one of the example
functions from the bindings,
which basically takes a raw
video input, raw audio input,
and output to WebM
file on a device.
What I did, I already created
the new application.
Here's the main activity file
which you probably all know.
And I already downloaded the
NI bindings, set them up.
I already downloaded all the
dependent open source projects
and set them up.
I did that basically from
the readme.android.
It gives you all the steps how
to do it, run through.
It's pretty easy.
We actually had a demo of when
I tried to create a new
project from scratch, download
everything, add the audio and
video encoding and show
the video file
in under five minutes.
It works sometimes, but we had
to cut it, because it was a
little confusing.
And we didn't have much time.
We're already kind of running
a little late, as it is.
So I'm going to copy the code
from the readme.android and
add it to my main
file on Create.
This is the code that will do
the audio and video encoding.
I will update my includes.
And I'm going to set my video
input file that I already
pushed in my device on
external storage.
I'm going to set
my audio file.
Again, I already pushed.
Save this, and now I'm
going to switch
to the Android device.
So this is probably the
simplest example.
I'm just reading the audio and
video input file on the device
in external storage
and writing it
out to external storage.
So let me show you that there is
no WebM file on the device.
I kind of feel like
a magician.
There's no cards up my sleeve.
And now I'm going to run the
application on the device.
So it's a pretty boring
application.
It won't do too much.
OK.
I agree.
There we go.
I said it's not going
to do too much.
It'll either say success,
it's done, or error.
OK, good.
Success.
So let's go back to
the explorer.
Hit refresh.
Should have a WebM file.
Let me play it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Drop!
[GUN SHOT]
[EXPLOSION]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
FRANK GALLIGAN: There we go.
So it worked.
It's nice when your first
demo works, you know.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
FRANK GALLIGAN: You
do it 100 times.
It works every time.
You get up here, and
everything changes.
So now I'll go back
to the slides.
Maybe.
All right.
So I'm going to go into a little
bit of the code, the
example code, that I used from
the bindings project.
The first set of slides is
setting up the audio and video
encoders, also the muxer.
You can see we're creating
libvpx configure object.
We're passing in the width
and the height
of the source video.
This is really important
because libvpx
not scale the video.
At this point, neither
will the binding.
So whenever you're creating on
the input, it's going to be on
the output.
I'm also, in the example code
I'm showing, setting the
target bitrate to
1,000 kilobits.
This is your most important
setting.
This is a setting you will
always change depending on
your use case for your
application.
For example, you could have--
creating a really small
video, like 160 by 120
for whatever reason.
You're going to set your target
bit, right, maybe to
100 kilobits.
Or you could be encoding
HD, and you
set it at three megabits.
Whatever it is, this is the one
you're going to change.
As John said before, a nice
feature of libvpx is the most
part, most of your applications,
you don't have
to change the other settings.
The defaults will be fine for
95% of the applications.
If you do have a very specific
need, there are other options
like if you need to set the key
frame target, if you have
certain seeking requirements or
maybe the quantizer values,
depending if you want to not go
too high- the bit rate to
not go too high or go too low.
But for the most part, you set
the target bit rate, and
everything else is fine.
Here I'm just creating the
Vorbis configure object for
passing in a number of channels,
sample rate, bits
per sample of the audio.
It's pretty easy.
This code is setting the time
base for both the VP8 encoder
and the Vorbis encoder.
This is really a convenience
function because the muxer,
the WebM expects the time base
to be nanosecond units.
And the only reason we're doing
this is that we don't
have to translate the
time stamps later.
If you didn't do this, the video
default time base is
milliseconds, and the audio
default time base is samples
per second.
Oop--
a nanoseconds unit.
Here, we're just creating
the encoder and
passing config objects--
config fig objects--
very simple.
At this point, both the
VP8 and the Vorbis
encoder are set up.
They're ready to start
encoding data.
The next two lines are
setting up the muxer.
The first line is we're creating
a writer object.
And basically what that is is
it implements a very simple
I/O interface.
So if your application had
different I/O needs, maybe you
had a packed file, whatever it
is, you can create your own
writer object that implements
the MPAV writer interface.
And you pass that
to the muxer.
They did the default
writer interface--
just uses the standard I/O,
f-open, f-write, f-close.
Here we're telling it the file
to write to, just a string, a
path and a file name output.
And if you're writing to
external storage in the
device, you just have to make
sure that you set the correct
permission on your Android
application.
Otherwise it won't work, and
it might get a little
confusing as to why
it's not working.
But there it is right there.
Here we're just creating
the muxer object
passing in the writer.
Now we're adding the audio
and video track.
We save the track numbers
for later.
This is how the muxer
distinguishes between the
different tracks is you pass
it the track number.
The first two parameters are
both pretty self-explanatory,
same as the config objects.
The third parameter to the ad
track is if you explicitly
need to set a track number.
For most applications,
you won't need it.
Passing in zero to libwebm
says you pick the number.
I'm OK with that.
And the last part of this set up
for the muxer is the Vorbis
audio needs some private data.
So you have to set the codec
private, which is basically
what it says.
It's data that's only
interpreted by the codec.
Again, if you use the Vorbis
encoder from the orange boxes,
it makes it pretty simple.
You call codec private.
It'll return the data in the
correct format, you set it,
and you're good to go.
So at this point, everything's
set up.
And now we're getting into
our encoding loop.
I kind of have some
pseudo-code.
I just say get the raw frame.
The audio--
the raw data is just an array
of PCM samples per-- libvpx,
the raw data is an I420
or YV12 frame.
I'll talk a little bit more
about color formats when we
get to the encode call.
If the raw data is audio,
it's pretty simple.
We just call encode, give
it the raw data.
Then we get the compress
frame.
I see I'm getting close on time,
so I'll try to go quick.
For Vorbis, you had to check to
make sure the encoded frame
is not null, because Vorbis
needs a certain amount of
input samples before
it'll start passing
back encoded data.
First parameter is the
encoded frame.
Second parameter is the
track number that
we passed back before.
Time stamp, already in the
correct time base.
And the last parameter is a
flag, a boolean saying if it's
a key frame or not.
All Vorbis audio frames
are key frames.
It's video.
Again, we pass the encode
frame I420.
We also have another function
call, because libvpx will only
take I420 or YB12.
But the libvpx wrapper will take
some RGB color space as
well as some other
YUV color spaces.
And what it'll do is it'll get
the raw frames, send it to
libyuv to convert it to I420
and then send it to libvpx.
Time stamp duration has to
be in time stamp units.
The libvpx encode
frame returns an
array of encoded packets.
This is because the libvpx
encoder can create what we
call altref frame, which is
basically a frame that must be
decoded in order
but not shown.
We loop through the array
of encoded packets.
The only real difference
at the end--
we check to see if the libvpx
packet is a key frame.
Then we pass that.
Oop-- hit the wrong button.
And finally we tell the muxer
segment to finalize the
segment which basically will
output seek points if you want
then, which by default
was yes.
And it will also seek back to
the beginning and update
header values so the file
will be playable.
John, you want to go to--
JOHN LUTHER: Why don't
you do your slides?
I'll do the YouTube demo,
because it can
take a little while.
Anyway, this is where you
can download this stuff.
I'm just going to talk very
briefly about VP9, which is
our next generation codec.
It's also free, open.
We don't charge any
money for it.
The big point with
VP9 is shhhh.
He uses the same quality as
VP8 and H.264 high profile
using up to half the data.
Saw it during the keynote.
Linus Upson demonstrated VP9
playing side by side with a
264 video and you could
see that the 264
data rate was up here.
VP9 was about half.
This'll start rolling
out in YouTube and
Chrome in Q3 of 2013.
We're getting pretty aggressive
about rolling this
out, because everybody involved
is pretty excited
about the data savings.
Bandwidth is still extremely
expensive business cost.
People keep thinking that it's
free or that it's going to
become cheaper, but
it never does.
So anyway, there was a
session yesterday.
You can watch the video on
YouTube later or download the
slides from that.
And that's all I'm going
to say on VP9.
You all get to the really
exciting demo.
FRANK GALLIGAN: Right.
So the YouTube demo, it captured
video and audio from
the camera and the microphone,
press in real time, then
uploaded to YouTube.
Just looking at it, wait
and processing.
If it comes up, maybe
we can play it.
Otherwise we can take some
really, really quick
questions, if anybody has any.
Just step up to the mike.
And then we'll also have
Q&A afterwards too.
JOHN LUTHER: Yeah, you can
find us afterwards.
AUDIENCE: Glad to hear you
guys are from OnTo.
I actually used the OnTo encoder
probably a decade ago
to do some video for web.
Great quality at the time.
A question for you is for
people that are video
producers, is it easy to
integrate the encoder into
something like Sony Vegas on the
PC or whatever's commonly
used on the Mac?
JOHN LUTHER: We have DirectShow
and QuickTime
components for the encoder and
decoder that plug into pretty
much all those tools.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a computer engineer.
And for us, it's always beat
into us that there's
always a trade off.
And when you guys are talking
about this, you're saying it's
low CP utilization, very good
compression ratio, and it
still looks as good.
It makes me wonder like
what's the catch?
And if there isn't, why isn't
there one and why have all the
previous ones failed to do
it as good as this has.
FRANK GALLIGAN: There's
no catch.
I mean, encoding
video is a very
expensive operation, right?
So when we say it's
low quality--
I mean, it's high quality,
Low CPU--
it's compared to what the
other current codec is.
JOHN LUTHER: Right.
And the other thing is you are
losing something in that the
raw source has everything.
Even like I said, that stuff
that your eye can't even see.
So throw all that out.
Like in editing bays, and people
who do pre-production,
they keep lost lists versions of
files around to do editing.
But then once it's encoded,
there's so much in that you
just really--
for the human eye to see
or anything else, you
just don't need it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FRANK GALLIGAN: Here.
I think this is what we took,
so hopefully, it'll--
JOHN LUTHER: Aaww.
There's a kitty.
FRANK GALLIGAN: So we had a
little Easter egg, too.
We had to show this little cat
that we overlaid on the video
that we upload to encode.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
JOHN LUTHER: I think we could
do one more question.
There's also hats.
It wouldn't be I/O
without swag.
So anybody who wants a free hat
with a handsome WebM logo,
see me afterwards.
Sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, name
is Mauricio.
I like to know you see VP8 and
VP9 being used for video
calling in mobile devices.
FRANK GALLIGAN:
Video-conferencing?
AUDIENCE: Used for
videocalling from mobile devices.
Either VP8 or VP9.
JOHN LUTHER: I mean, part
of the webRTC--
are you familiar with WebRTC?
We're trying to recommend it
or we have as a mandatory
implement code for WebRTC.
It's what you were using with
our WebRTC at Google.
It's one of things that--
we had so little time.
I had an earlier draft of these
gone into why VP is also
a very, very good codec, maybe
in some ways better than for
visual, for video on demand.
Its real time capabilities for
RTC are pretty amazing.
So the answer is yes.
AUDIENCE: So on the same line,
one of the great things about
the opus codec, which you
mentioned is coming in WebM,
is its real time performance.
It's very, very low latency.
What kind of latencies can you
achieve with VP8 or VP9.
FRANK GALLIGAN: Well, VP8, you
can achieve some frame-- so
one frame latency.
AUDIENCE: So like like 8,
9, 10 milliseconds.
FRANK GALLIGAN: Yeah.
I mean, it depends
on your options.
Whatever options you pick,
we try to keep it like 30
milliseconds or whatever.
Maybe one frame latency.
You can always turn off your
options to get it to 8, 9, 10
milliseconds latency.
But then your quality might
not be as good.
AUDIENCE: Right.
FRANK GALLIGAN: So we try to
keep it to one-frame latency.
VP9--
we'll still working on it, but
we have the same target when
it comes out.
I think it's Q3 or
4 this year.
JOHN LUTHER: Q3.
I mean, the bitstream is--
FRANK GALLIGAN: For real time.
JOHN LUTHER: The bitstream
will be frozen in June.
And then--
FRANK GALLIGAN: Yeah, for
real times, it's Q--
JOHN LUTHER: For real time, I'm
sorry, Q4, yeah, when we
build it in real time.
They keep giving us more time.
It's like it's running backwards
or something.
So anyway, it you want a
hat, come and see us.
If you have any other questions,
feel free.
FRANK GALLIGAN: And
we'll be out.
And it's online.
JOHN LUTHER: We'll be
out in the booth.
So thanks everybody.
FRANK GALLIGAN: Thank you.